imagina que estamos trabajando con
series geométricas que vamos a trabajar
con series geométricas y que además
conocemos algunas cosas importantes de
estas series geométricas vamos a
fijarnos en una en particular así que
aquí tengo series geométricas lo primero
que voy a decir es que conocemos su
primer término así que voy a llamar a
a su primer término déjame escribirlo es
su primer primer término
y bueno también voy a suponer que
conocemos su razón común voy a decir que
r es su razón razón o proporción común
razón
y bueno voy a decir que estoy trabajando
con una serie finita lo que quiere decir
que tienen un número finito de términos
así que voy a suponer que n n es igual a
la cantidad de términos que tenemos es
decir el número de términos
entonces n va a ser igual al número de
términos y bueno por último voy a llamar
a ese subíndice n a ese subíndice n estã
de aquí va a ser la suma
d
primero
n
en términos sn va a ser la suma de los
primeros n términos y yo lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es encontrar una
expresión para referirnos a la suma de
los primeros n términos es decir
proponer una fórmula general para esta
suma de los primeros n términos una
fórmula para evaluar series geométricas
así que pues empecemos escribamos que s
n s n va a ser la suma de los primeros
en eternos entonces vamos a escribirlos
en primer término se llama a por lo
tanto lo voy a poner aquí
le voy a sumar el segundo término pero
piense en segundo término bueno el
segundo término va a ser lo mismo que el
primer término por la razón común es
decir voy a poner aquí a am ya está la
voy a multiplicar por una razón común es
decir me va a quedar
eres mi segundo terno y después quiero
tomarme el tercer término a esto le voy
a sumar el tercer término
bueno pues tienes mi tercer término
observa que va a ser tomarme el segundo
término y multiplicarlo de nuevo por la
razón común eso quiere decir que va a
ser a r por r o dicho de otra manera a
que multiplica a r elevada al cuadrado y
bien podemos seguir sumando y sumando y
sumando hasta llegar a los n términos
déjame ponerlo así hasta que lleguemos
al último término al enésimo término y
quién va a ser el enésimo termino bueno
puedes estar tentado a decir que es a
que multiplica a r elevado a la n pero
ten cuidado porque observa que nuestro
primer término es a o lo podemos ver
como a que multiplica a r elevado a la
potencia cero y después nuestro segundo
términos a que multiplica a r elevado a
la primera potencia y nuestro presente
nos
la que multiplica ha elevado a la
segunda potencia y así nos podemos
seguir y seguir si te das cuenta en
cualquier término que estemos el
exponente es el número de término menos
uno entonces sí estamos en el enésimo
término vamos a tener a que multiplica r
elevado a la potencia n menos uno y
bueno como queremos obtener una fórmula
linda y limpia para evaluar esto podemos
usar un pequeño truco y para hacer esto
en lo que vamos a pensar es en la
multiplicación de esta suma ese
subíndice n por r es decir no voy a
tomar r veces la suma ese subíndice n
ese subíndice n y después cuando me tomé
la resta de estas dos se van a ir
simplificando y eliminando muchos
términos en el lado derecho es más de
una vez vamos a hacer lo voy a
multiplicar esta suma pero por menos r
para que aquí me quede este signo
negativo y veas cómo se van a ir
cancelando los términos así que se
multiplicó cada uno de estos sumandos
por menos r que me va a quedar
bueno pues observa que se multiplicó
menos r por el primer término déjame
ponerlo así lo voy a poner justo acá
porque nos va a ayudar a eliminar este
de aquí déjame poner que voy a
multiplicar por menos r así que estoy
tomándome el primero y multiplicando lo
por menos r y que obtengo bueno pues
observa que el signo me va a quedar
negativo y después tengo a por r lo cual
es a ver déjame escribirlo así
x
de lujo y si ahora multiplicó el segundo
término por menos r
déjame ponerlo así ahora voy a tomarme
el segundo término y lo voy a
multiplicar por menos r y lo voy a poner
aquí lo voy a multiplicar al punto menos
r que me va a quedar
bueno pues observa que esto no se cambia
más por menos es menos entonces me va a
quedar aquí un signo negativo y después
tengo a erc que multiplica a r esto es
lo mismo que a ere cuadrada estás de
acuerdo a que multiplica a r por r es lo
mismo que a ere cuadrada re cuadrada y
creo que ya estás viendo a dónde va todo
esto los estoy poniendo justo acá abajo
porque cuando sume estas dos se van a ir
cancelando todos los términos y que me
va a quedar bueno pues así me voy a
seguir restando y restando y restando
hasta llegar al penúltimo término y
bueno este se ve de la siguiente manera
se ve como a que multiplica
elevado a la n 2 porque es el penúltimo
estás de acuerdo y si a eso lo
multiplicamos por menos
rm que me va a quedar es si no me queda
negativo y me queda
a que multiplica a ere elevado a la n 1
si el anterior a este es a que
multiplica a r elevado a la enee menos 2
y a eso lo multiplicamos por r me va a
quedar que la a sigue igual y la r queda
elevada a la n 1 y si me fijo en el
último término quien va a ser sea este
de aquí lo multiplicó por menos r
a este de aquí lo multiplicó por menos r
que me va a quedar bueno primero voy a
tener un signo negativo más x menos es
menos y después observa que a que
multiplica a r elevado a la n 1 y esto
lo multiplicamos por r es lo mismo que
am que multiplica a r elevado a la n
fíjate bien r elevado a la n 1 que
multiplica su vez r a la primera
potencia bueno pues eso va a ser r
elevado a la n iv ahora lo que es muy
interesante kim es que si me agarró la
suma del lado izquierdo y del lado
derecho
estas igualdades que tengo aquí que me
va a quedar pues hagámoslo me voy a
tomar la suma de estos dos y la suma de
todo esto que tengo aquí y que voy a
obtener del lado izquierdo
bueno observa que voy a obtener ese
subíndice n ese subíndice n menos
- r veces ese subíndice n
ese subíndice en esto es lo que me queda
del lado izquierdo y del lado derecho o
del lado derecho va a pasar algo súper
padre se van a cancelar muchos de estos
términos y date cuenta que solamente me
voy a quedar con esta am me voy a quedar
con esta app y con este de aquí cuando
es del final porque todos los demás
observan se van a cancelar aquí tengo
que multiplicar positivo y aquí lo tengo
negativo entonces estos dos se van a
cancelar y después aquí tengo más
cuadrada y aquí
- r cuadrada por lo tanto todos se van a
cancelar y así voy a seguir cancelando y
cancelando y cancelando hasta que llegó
a este a que multiplica a r elevado a la
n 1 y aquí lo tengo en negativo esos 2
también se van a cancelar y solamente me
voy a quedar con este último con este
último que puedo escribir así como menos
am que multiplica a r elevado
y ya casi acabamos porque si ahora
podemos resolver para ese subíndice n
tendremos nuestra fórmula que buscábamos
desde un principio entonces déjame bajar
un poco la pantalla y vamos a resolver
esto bueno pues si del lado derecho
sacamos como factor común a ese
subíndice en el factor izamos a ese
subíndice en el que me va a quedar bueno
ese subíndice en el que va a multiplicar
a quien primero multiplica a uno para
obtener ésta ese subíndice n uno menos y
después multiplica a r después
multiplica a r para obtener estas tres
veces ese subíndice n entonces del lado
derecho factor hizo a ese subíndice n y
del lado izquierdo puedo factorizar
puedo factorizar
entonces me va a quedar am
a que multiplica a quién bueno pues
observa que primero multiplica a uno
para obtener esta am a que multiplica a
uno y llegamos a esta am y después
multiplica a r elevado a la n - r
elevado a la n y ya está del lado
derecho factor izamos está a y ya casi
acabamos con un poco de álgebra vamos a
poder obtener esta suma que nosotros
queríamos el valor de ese n porque a
quien va a ser igual
bueno pues ese subíndice n va a ser
igual a a que multiplica a 1 - r elevado
a la n entre 1 - r esto lo voy a pasar
dividiendo entonces me va a quedar de la
siguiente manera a que multiplica a 1 -
r a la n esto a su vez va a estar
dividido entre m
- ere y ya está pudimos averiguar cuánto
era esta suma que nosotros estábamos
buscando
esta suma ese subíndice n que es la suma
para los primeros n términos de una
serie geométrica y bueno recuerda que la
serie geométrica era finita en los
próximos vídeos aplicaremos esta fórmula
y te invito a que siempre que uses esta
fórmula recuerdes que es muy importante
de dónde viene porque ahora ya sabes de
dónde viene esta fórmula
así que manténlo presente cuando estés
resolviendo un ejercicio y bueno a veces
puedes tener una anotación de sigma la
anotación sigma puede empezar no se
puede empezar en cero es decir en su
primer término n va a tomar el valor de
0 e ir hasta un cierto número en este
caso debes de tener mucho cuidado porque
esa serie tiene un término además
entonces tienes que ser muy cuidadoso
es el primer término n es el número de
eternos lo definimos acá arriba
recuerdas y r es nuestra razón común